okay thanks Andy
and thanks Dennis for inviting me
welcome everybody in the room I'm going
to talk about linear and artificial life
i'm perd Shen from Hong Kong
hi I'm a software and data engineer by
day and in my spare time I do
independent research in topics like
artificial life or even human evolution
I also make infographics or typeface
first we only introduce artificial life
or a life and linear and then we talk
about the biology of Danya we have some
further discussions and a cure a session
we first talked abouts about it for the
contest about artificial life in biology
we try to collect and study existing
organisms and we try to classify them
and figure out how they work but in
artificial life or a life we instead
simulate life or create new forms of
life and try to answer questions like
what is life or what life can be we have
a few approaches in what a life we use
synthetic biology and biochemistry to
hack the beginning and create artificial
cells in happy life we are prying
robotics and electrical or mechanical
engineering to create robots and
machines like this you can see this
human
with robots Alice they can do a backflip
or this strand beast built by Phil yawns
in the third approaches software a life
that we do computer simulations of life
we also can talk about art in a life
that all these beautiful graphics and
installations that they are actually
artworks
in fact we can consider AI as part of a
life because things like artificial
neural networks they are inspired by the
neurons in the brain and genetic
algorithms that be inspired by the
process of evolution so they are
actually trying to replicate the success
stories of life will not focus on
computer simulations of life like other
compress systems or chaotic systems we
start from very simple rules and we can
see the emergence of complex life like
patterns or behaviors there are some
classic models like Vida that simulates
the evolution process or points that
simulates the flocking behavior of birds
we have systems that simulate evolution
to involve new creatures like virtual
creatures pioneered by councils or the
stock robots that they can learn how to
swim
how to walk we have models like cellular
automata and aeration diffusion systems
that they can generate interesting life
patterns and we also have particle
systems that simulates chemical
molecules like a swarm chemistry or
primordial political systems
that's you may heard about them talking
about soft robots recently in earlier
this week we have a big news
that's a team of a joint team of a life
researchers that they just announced
that they created the first-ever living
robots they first use computer to evolve
soft robots for a certain task like
walking and then they transferred a
final design the virtual design to real
frog selves and amazingly their cells
start to walk so it's like a cross over
between soft a life and wet day life so
the story of lennier
begins in the 1990s and while I got my
first PC with eight megahertz 8286 CPU
and I'm you remember this was a turbo
button to turn it into 16 megahertz so I
got this PC and I use Pascal the Pokemon
language to write simulations of many
models like gravity strange attractors
the Mandelbrot set and also the Conway's
Game of Life the common scheme of life
is cellular automaton or CA the Creator
by John Conway you should heard about
this before is basically a QT
rectangular grid of cells each cell has
state of 0 1 that means that were like a
life and each cell has a local
neighborhood of its neighboring cells
this update rule for each each cell we
can to some of its ex neighbors and we
use a simple if the house statement or
rule to decide the next stage of the
cell and then we apply this rule to the
whole grid of all the cells and we
repeat the updating of the grid again
and again and we start to seize many
interesting patterns to emerge like this
you may see this graders are moving and
also we see we can discover a trade
against that amidst discards we can also
use these traders and cardigans and
other objects to build not a case and
finally we can build a virtual computer
inside the game of life so it can
actually do any kind of calculation in
this virtual world or we can say that
the game of life is Turing compete so at
that time I started to play with the
rules of game of life for the 0 Orleans
States fine how about allowing multiple
values or making them floating-point
numbers for the simple eight neighbors
why not make it a wider longer range or
making circular in shape is also is
boring to just candlelight neighbors so
I tried to
I use weight asam and the weights
distributor is a ring or concentric
concentric rings that is equals to the
calculation of convolution of the cells
with a circular kernel about the
if-then-else
update we can use mapping functions
instead and we can make the update
incremental so all these change I made
and programmed making everything
continues and the system no longer is
just no longer discrete like the
original game of life so and then
something really strange happened I
start to see this guy moving on the
screen at that time I was still printing
our numbers so this row and then I put
these numbers into Excel and start to
see these beautiful shapes and then I'm
fine
more moving or rotating in patterns so
what's happening here and then we so we
now enter the world of Danielle I give
this name because not in it means smooth
creatures mathematically is a continuous
CA in 2d or 3d or higher dimensions the
update rule can be expressed by this
formula that means we have a array an
array of cells a and we apply coalition
with a carnival a circular con okay
and to calculate the rate a sum and then
we applied the mapping function G to
calculate the Delta and add a small
portion of the Delta back to the cells
in this model we have few parameters to
tune I call them mu sigma and beta so
far we discovered more than 500 species
of moving patterns and they look and
behave like microorganisms that we can
see in some random videos we start to
study their structures and dynamics and
we do statistics analysis the software
is the central part of this project I
wrote several versions of programming in
different languages like the earliest
version of web version you can print it
in your browser and other functions are
there then wrote a method version is
quite powerful and now we have a Python
version that is under active development
the program at sa kind of like
laboratory for doing observations or
experiments on the linear patterns is
like a bottle between our world and the
alien linear world to make the program
faster we use Fourier transform FFT the
calculate of convolution and all
to use you can also work in GPU and
maybe FPGA or GPU in the future there is
also an interactive UI that provides
lots of tools for you to manipulate the
sales or do numerical analysis I will
demo the program now so this is the
Python program this is the first life
form you see in the slide I call it
orbeum and in it it has I I have a GPU
so it's using GPU
I will show more about this program
later in this talk this is the data flow
of the whole project
how are used to open the main program is
linear UI the read data from JSON file
that have other specimens of the
patterns it generates images and allow
us to observe and to experiments I also
wrote a c-sharp program that is linear
auto to automatically generate lots of
statistical data then I feed all this
data into huge excel file and to queens
explore and visualize the data in the
future is actually and the heavy
determine will have a linear API that
includes all these personalities of a
linear you are in the new Authority cell
that can be run on crowd like Google
collab the book that means we can use
the GPU on the collab so linear has been
growing into a large project a software
that I put on github and also there is
life at this art this is a showcase
video that won't some awards in Japan
conferences I wrote a research paper and
is published in archives and composite
systems
I'm also having talks about artificial
life and we are I'm starting to thinking
through the further research in like
crossover in a life and I the second
party out have more details about the
biology of lennier with the demo program
I will show some demo to you imagine we
discovered some alien life in on Mars or
on Europa or some EXO parent planet for
example those ones in the novel novel
Solaris by Senator phlegm this kind
asymmetry out if we discovered this
life-form we may try to communicate with
them maybe there's some musical notes or
some scientists may try to study them
these life-forms should be very
different from the life in on earth they
may have no eyes maybe no arms or the to
even use DNA or they may be not
carbon-based but it's possibly they they
we have some basic principles that is
coming with terrestrial life like
symmetry or evolution or entropy
minimizing the entropy so it's
reasonable to use the parol concepts or
terminology from biology we can talk
about like kisana me or ecology
or the morphology of behavior or didn't
even physiology of these life-forms the
same applies to linear evolution here
means how can we create new patterns or
life-forms in in this virtual world the
term is called intuitive evolutionary
computation or IEC is a process to
manually simulate natural selection like
a mutation selection or reproduction
there are several ways to evolve new
species in my experience we can
[Music]
randomize the grid and see if there's
some random moving patterns come out
from the soup
we can also trick or tune the parameters
and sometimes I am assisting species
will turn into a new species we can also
use a program to automatically do a grid
search to search for lots of new
patterns and also we can do many
mutations like cutting I like the fly
from graph and stuck it back and see if
it will turn into a new species
and we can do this in this Python
program so we can randomize the degreed
and see if there's anything come out not
yet okay sometimes we see Opium's come
out from almost or we can start from it
is existing my farm can save stabilizes
and we can change the parameters now I
change Sigma it will turn into a
slightly different life form that is
it's not oscillating
after this process of creating new like
new patterns or life-forms we can start
study their basic properties of
space-time this like scum some kind of
fundamental physics the patterns we find
that the patterns are invariants with
the scaling of space-time or the
functions that used in the kernel or
mapping or the patterns will persist in
under some transformations or
deformations so is a very interesting
phenomenon in India we can scale the
space-time and then skill the space up
here no I'm not suing the image is
actually changing the the cells array
and also changing the kernel so it's
actually changing the grid at the rules
but the patency resists we can also
change time like maybe faster let's see
it faster the keys lower slower for
slower time I mean I think more
abortions of Delta in the update rule so
again I'm changing the rule it's not
fast forward or slow motion
in the in the carnal or in the mapping
function we can use other functions like
now I'm using a smooth function so the
pattern is smooth I can use step
functions like this one oops
you can use step function and it still
persists but the shape change beats the
gesture change to the beat we can also
scale or rotates the pattern and these
two here
let's make some noise as some noise to
the pattern and is to here so is the
basic properties of these patterns in
linear we can you will proceed even if
it to such drastic changes to date
there are trillions of zillions of
insects on earth and apologists try to
put them into different taxa by species
genus family or others a structure in
and then here we it happens that we can
also apply this kind of classification
to the patterns into different taxa of
different ranks if a number of samples
of the life-forms have if they have
continuous variations one can be moved
into another one's smoothly then we can
say we can group them into a species
likewise if they we can cook several
species into if they have minor
differences we can crop them into a
genus and put different genera with
similar building blocks into a family
and so on we also give a Panama binomial
name to each species so we can easier to
identify them like the one I show is is
called opium Unicode artists and so now
we have systematic classification system
that we can tell which one is which we
can see in this chart on the left there
we discovered 18 families in Lenya so
they all have different structures and
behaviors
we can talk about the geography or
ecology of Lenya for different life
forms they have different values of mu
and Sigma that is they are the
parameters of the mapping function G so
if we try to plot these values in
parameter space we will get a map you
can see the map here with colors and
with the shape of the life forms it
shows that this each species occupy a
continuous area in the parameter space
and I call these areas habitats or niche
we can see that most most species they
occupy the central diagonal line in the
middle this line has a name it's called
the nature of chaos that means these
life-forms living between the area that
nothing happens and between total chaos
so these life forms actually corresponds
to orphans cross for CAS also for the
beta parameters for the kernel we can
create say beta crib that is another
kind of map and the species occupies
certain areas on this cube
in the study of morphology of linear
life-forms we find certain prominent
features like the most striking one is
symmetry and how symmetry and behaviors
are correlated we find many kinds of
symmetry in linear like a bilateral
radio rotational spherical or spiral
symmetries with bilateral symmetry the
patterns have very fast like no
irrational movement with radio symmetry
the iPhone is either slow-moving or a
stationary or rotating there are many
life forms there segmented or turmeric
that is they are composed of repeating
components and that can make really
really long chains some life forms are
made up of a swarm of granada' masses
there are more freestyle in the
structure and behavior our show tees in
the program
so this obvious again we can turn the
polar mode on this is the polar mode and
it detects that it has bilateral
symmetry
this one has radial symmetry is
pentameric five folds radio symmetry and
it's stationary this one it has sex fold
radial symmetry and is slowly moving oh
and also this one is radio what it has
rotational symmetry and is rotating I'm
a tree using the polar coordinates and
also a fattie to detect the symmetry so
it's the polar mode and we are back to
normal mode this pattern has cementation
yes one two three four sevens and I'll
show you some more patterns like this
one is longer or some some longer ones
like this one this one is with the swarm
architectures as granular masses is is
freely moving and there's some kind of
amoeba a Bieber like a life formed that
is moving freely in the grid
one interesting thing is in nature we
also find similar relationships between
the morphology and their movements in
bilateral animals like insects or
animals mammals we have fast moving we
can move fast to catch price in radio
symmetric animals like starfish
or coral jellyfish they're slow-moving
or just floating OC so we see segments
animals like crustaceans and insects
they the morphology become very
versatile and we are there also swarm
like amoeba so the similarity between
real and virtual life-forms are
staggering in the study of the behavior
of life-forms we can summarize the
global movements or locomotion into four
types they are stationary rotational
irrational and gyrating there are many
types of local movements for kids like
solid or oscillating or alternating more
interesting are those irregular or
chaotic movements some of them will just
rendering around well we found a need
single Direction some of them even
engage in metamorphosis they that is
extremely clear
that is reached shape-shift among
different modes there are also particle
rations that's a very interesting
phenomena like fusion fission or
refraction etc there are four types of
overall movement a one is directional
movements this one is stationary just
stay here oscillating this is direction
now this is gyrating also this is forty
rotating so these four kinds of movement
about local movement at this one you see
this is moving but actually is also
quite solid so it has no local movement
this one is oscillating and this one is
alternating from left to right to left
so it's like walking or
we show some chaotic behavior at this
one is very stable it's a lot more
chromium and this one is more chaotic
the sea is like rendering around with
different directions and this one is
shape-shifting you see now is moving
rendering in Kyoto direction we need
faster sometimes if you stop and change
into a rotating pattern let's see yeah
now it's just changing into a stationary
pattern and then change back to a moving
pattern yeah you know change to a
oscillating pattern
also particle reactions the first slow a
an opium praise some more you will see
some particle collision and sometimes
they will eat each others and sometimes
they will have other kinds of
interactions okay they fuse together
into the fuse together into another life
form
in Balaji we have bike and small regions
within or between species like these
beetles I saw in Korean trip there are
very subtle variations inside a species
the same is true in any er so we want to
do quantitative quantitative analysis on
the structures and behaviors to see the
subtle variations first we decide which
kind of measurements to take like mass
size shape linear speed or angular
angular speed etc and then we calculate
and collect these measurements for lots
of life forms with lots of these
statistical data we can now plot graphs
like this one on the top is mass versus
parameter Sigma now we can discover some
trends or subtle variations among these
life-forms that they actually change
into another species when we changed the
parameter also this chart in the bottom
approach speed versus mass and we can
discover some interesting collision
correlations which in these measurements
this is also possible to find statistics
right just now we show that you can
attack symmetry
and also detect the oscillating period
and also trt city
this one is gyrating erbium so this is
the statistical mode you can see this
mass growth change over time that create
a phase space trajectory we can change
to other statistics like size artists
this is some distance this is speed this
is angular speed there is periodic Ram
that is used to detect the period of
this pattern so it's detected is period
is point eight seven second in this
virtual world now you have some further
discussions about linear in artificial
life with the discovery of linear and
also smooth life we can now classify
this cellular automata by the level of
continuity we have the original CAS it
is christie's like the game of life
there are geometrical CS like lenio
there also continuous CAS like real life
in this script CAS
the patterns are very precise but also
very fragile that means they're easy to
be disrupted we change one cell and the
pattern is gone the patterns are also
digital that means some rules can
literally do calculations thanks to the
turing completeness in geometric CS
patterns are fuzzy but resilient they
can proceed they persist from changes or
collisions they are also analog and
lifelike continuous the real continuous
CAS are purely mathematical models if we
scale up linear so that the kernel goes
to infinity lush and will approach the
continuum limit continuum limits of a
truly continuous CA so continuous
continuous es this actually we can't do
simulation but we can approximate it by
things like lenio we find quite a few
similarities between the earth and
terrestrial and mainly our life
they are both vivid eye catching and
actually quite beautiful like this video
will show some count jellies a video
from aquarium and also a life form is
anemia
I called come back
they the both world both exhibit great
biodiversity the patterns or the
life-forms exhibit phenotypic plasticity
that means are they all can adapt to
changes and undergo evolution I have a
hypothesis that it seems like symmetry
provides stability and asymmetry in the
structure provides motility the ability
to move so I think these rules can be a
product to both the real life forms and
the virtual life forms the ultimate
question is what is life well how can we
define life one may say that okay I know
it when I see it I think is this
statement is actually true because so
far the human brain is the past life
pattern we can we can know this life
when we see this structure and we see it
moving so I think that we can trust the
human brain in this task but more
precisely we can define life by couple
of capabilities like self-organization
self-regulation self-replication etc
linear exhibits a number of these
capabilities so
can we say that the patents in lennier
is a life or are they partially alive
the same situation happens in
astrobiology or by virtue can we say
that a virus is a life or when we see
some objects in in space that is moving
in some peculiar way and can how can we
determine that these special objects are
life
these are all subject to debate here are
some future directions to ask - OH - we
can work on I want to answer a few
questions that is related to the
relative cellular automata like is there
any self replicator in Lenya or is there
any limit of patents like like those
great again in the game of life and is
lenio Turing complete can it used to
perform a computation we can explore
some variations like hard dimensions or
parallel universe
I'm now making a API and probably a data
set they can be used to do data science
or machine learning using linear as a
substrate to to
and based on that we can start to think
how to do crossover research between a
life and AI for example how can we apply
AI methodologies like genetic a
preference or deep learning to to to
object detection or automated search on
a a life system we can we start to see
some 3-d and 4-d patterns that's very
interesting but a C can be shown but you
can see them in my Twitter I want to
introduce some related works in the
literature or some stop in progress
Steven roughness smooth life you see the
picture and in the top this is is also a
cellular continuous cellular automaton
discovered a few years ago is very
similar to linear and is actually a case
of independence discovery that we we
arrive to the similar system using
similar principles starting from the
game of life
on how to do automated search of
patterns we have py gudiya's - curiosity
driven cooperation algorithm we have
chanced an ease
neural information and no 14 Church or
the upper firm called meat that should
be very useful and their house works on
new evolution in deep learning Alex what
with test work on new OCA is in progress
he knows he making a hybrid of cellular
automata and new networks that can see
the bottom image you can use assimilate
some kind some kind of regeneration in
integrate and necrosis work he is doing
a FPGA chip for calculating cellular
automata and faster if you want to know
more about artificial life there are few
conferences or communities in mid-july
there will be a a live conference in
Montreal the film and main theme is what
can a life offer AI so interesting and
there is a small community in Lausanne a
called wine Association it is for topics
like artificial life or coins or
creativity that I meet these members
with ago in Hong Kong I also make a
Twitter list
of artificial life news so we can go to
this URL to these city sings that's all
and thank you for listening and by the
way I'm going at Keio yeah that's the
Q&A any questions it is set up but
pairing the microphone can you hear me
now yeah I can look around the Verizon
guy now okay questions
okay um yeah actually I saw the the the
the the slash nothing on the frog and it
was very whoa that's a little too creepy
for me today
you mean these patterns yeah yeah the
Frog cells and they were convinced oh
okay okay yeah these foxes there's the
coin programmable organism is actually
as I know is the very first stage so
it's kind of you have to do make the
cells by hand if it's not not ready for
mass production so it's not that kind of
people would start to finger thinking
about Terminator or Frankenstein but
actually it's not it's not already there
they are making progress but the
progress is very interesting I guess
have you used anything like evolutionary
algorithm or other more complicated
search algorithms other than grid search
to try to generate these life-forms
because I saw that you had done a few
different kinds of like randomness and
grid search but I was thinking that
maybe some kind of like more specific
kind of search algorithms may give you
different or new life-forms did you hear
the question yeah I get it okay yes the
method I use is called interactive
evolutionary computation that's a
methodology inside evolution in
computation so is actually using some
kind of menu process to to to simulate
natural selection is the process is not
automated so in this feedback or these
manipulations from human you server so
I'm planning to study other kinds of
automated search program mechanisms and
try to - lamian like those ones I
mentioned the works and in the genetic
algorithms or evolutionary performs they
have so many methodologies out there
that I have to try to apply to this
system so last thing you won't happen
well thank you very much and yes
it's daylight their last speaker was not
daylight where they were so cool thank
you okay thank you